el expresidente de ucrania pietro por 5
asegura que los cargos en su contra son
falsos y no son más que un intento del
actual presidente volodomir de lenski
por desviar la atención de su caída de
popularidad y manchar en la imagen de su
rival
señor selenski recuerde que debe volver
a su trabajo como comandante en jefe no
pelearse con el líder de la oposición
sobre todo porque no tiene ninguna
posibilidad de ganar esta batalla contra
naciones
las autoridades ucranianas dicen están
investigando decenas de presuntos
delitos en su contra a principios de
este mes un tribunal congeló los bienes
y propiedades de poroshenko el cargo más
grave alta traición conlleva una pena de
hasta 15 años de prisión hay sospechas
de que el exmandatario ayudó a los
separatistas pro rusos que controlan a
partes del este de ucrania a vender a
kiev carbón por un valor de casi 50
millones de euros entre 2014 y 2015 en
ese momento el control de los
separatistas de las minas de carbón
provocó una grave crisis energética las
embajadas occidentales subrayan la
importancia de un juicio independiente y
no político los diplomáticos también
cuestionan el momento en el que
poroshenko regresa justo cuando ucrania
acusa a rusia por concentrar tropas en
su frontera ante una posible invasión
los aliados de kiev dicen que lo que
necesita el país ahora es unidad no
división